[SQUEEKING] [RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Welcome
to lecture number 12.
I'm very sorry that
this has to be remote.
I hope all of you are doing OK.
I know this is lots
of trouble and stress
for many of you, having to
move, not knowing necessarily
where to move to, financial
issues and so on and so forth,
lots of worries about health,
of your own health and others.
I hope you're doing OK.
Try to take good care
of yourselves and others
try to look out for others,
be there for each other.
Try also to make use of mental
health resources as you can.
I'll send an email
about that as well.
This is lecture number 12.
We talk about
social preferences.
So we talked about
sort of broadly
given introduction about
social preferences.
Let me just move towards
where we were towards the end.
I showed you, essentially,
different ways
in which you can
experimentally elicit
people's social preferences
using dictator games, ultimatum
games, trust games.
We looked at how
generous do people
behave in those kinds of games?
Does it look like people
care about others,
they're nice towards others?
We then, to some degree, sort of
found quite a bit of generosity
in dictator games
and other games.
People seemed quite nice.
In some pieces of evidence,
it wasn't quite clear
whether it was is it
that people are generally
nice to each other, or is
it like they don't want
to look like a mean person,
either towards others
or perhaps towards themselves.
They want to think of themselves
as being a nice person,
and they don't want to be mean.
And that might be a motivation
of giving towards others.
In the games that
have shown you so far,
it wasn't quite clear
how to distinguish that.
So what we're going
to do in this lecture,
we're going to look at
some pieces of evidence
where there's versions of
dictator and other games
that lets us look at more the
underlying motivation of why
people give, and perhaps
detect, in some cases,
that when people are giving
in some situations which
look like people are
quite nice, in fact,
that might not be
because they generally
care about the other person.
It might be rather either
because of social image
concerns-- is this about what
other people think about them
if they give versus not--
or because of
self-image concerns,
these are, like, what do they
think of themselves, as in you
give to somebody else not
necessarily because you care
about the other person,
or it might not even
be that you care about what
the other person thinks of you.
It's just about
you yourself want
to feel good about
yourself, and therefore you
might be generous because
you want to sort of keep
or maintain the image of being
a nice person to yourself
as well.
Some of the evidence that I'm
going to show you is-- you
wouldn't say
depressing, but it's
a little bit sort of negative in
the sense that essentially what
I'm going to show you is that
people appear, or in fact are,
if you believe that evidence,
less nice than it might appear.
So it says that last
time, at first sight,
it looks like that's a little
depressing or little negative
in the sense of we might be
disappointed that we thought
everybody was really
nice and friendly
and cared so much about others.
Maybe that's not quite true.
On the other hand, however,
if we sort of understand
the conditions under which
people are nice and friendly
to each other--
and in some ways, you
might sort of say,
well, it's not
obvious that we really
care that much about whether
people are generally nice
versus not.
What we really care
about, perhaps,
is how people, in fact, behave.
Are they friendly and prosocial
and support each other?
And perhaps if we understand the
conditions under which people
are nice and friendly
to each other,
perhaps that allows us, then,
to think about policies,
how do we set up--
in firms or in organizations
or in society as a whole--
how do we set up
policies that might make
people more prosocial overall.
So this lecture, we're going
to talk about more trying
to detect different motivations
for people's prosociality.
And then the next
lecture, we're going
to talk about now what are
some field evidence So all I'm
going to show you for now
is essentially mostly lab
evidence, but we're
going to show some field
evidence in real
world situations
in companies and so on,
or in field experiments,
how people are behaving.
And in particular,
we're going to think
about some policies that
might get people to be
more prosocial versus not.
So we already talked
about this as a whole.
So the first thing we
want to think about
is essentially
social recognition.
This is essentially
social image.
How do others think about
you when you give versus not?
So then I'm going to show
you now several papers,
or evidence from several
papers, that essentially does
different modifications, mostly
of the Dictator Game, that
allows us to disentangle
these different motivations.
So the first one is
the very nice paper
by Lazear et al that conduct
an experiment to study motives
for giving, as of many
dictator games do.
And they have essentially a very
simple design, two treatments.
One of them is the
standard dictator game.
This is what you
have seen before.
The only difference is
this one is in euros.
It's sort of, I
think, done in Europe.
Think of euros as just
being the same as dollars.
So people can decide to split
10 euros between themselves
and another subject.
In another treatment,
subjects decide
whether to even participate
in the Dictator Game.
So essentially, what's being
allowed here is an exit option.
You could essentially
say either you're
going to participate
in the dictator game
with another person, or
you could just decide
you don't even play this game.
And you get just get
some fixed payout.
Now then, if the dictator
chooses to participate,
the recipient is
informed of the game
and the choice of the dictator.
So the recipient
will be informed
and know about there was a
dictator game that was played.
Here's the amount that
the dictator chose.
Here's the amount that you got.
And then the standard dictator
game commences, and then
the recipient just
gets the money,
and the recipient is essentially
informed of the action.
So if you choose, for example,
9 euros for yourself and one
euros for the other person,
the other person will know that
the one euro that they got
came from a dictator game,
and there was somebody who chose
$9.00 for themselves and gave
$1.00 for them.
So then one option of this,
or one version of this game,
was essentially just like
a costless exit option.
That is essentially
the option where
you say you receive 10
euros without the option
of distributing the money.
Notice that that's
exactly the same
as choosing to opt into
the game and choosing 10-0
in terms of payouts.
If I just say I want
10 euros for myself,
I give nothing to
the other person,
that's exactly the same
as saying you opt out
of the dictator game.
The difference, of course,
is that if you opt out,
the participant will never
know that you opted out.
So the other person
will never find out
that somebody was
kind of mean to them.
And so you might sort of choose
the opt out option, perhaps
because you think the
other person will feel bad.
And if the other person feels
bad, you try and avoid that
and you might opt out.
This is kind of the exit option.
So the first option here, the
subject line of the slides,
is costly exit.
In this version of the game,
the exit is actually not costly.
It's costless to do so.
You can just essentially
take the $1.00 and run,
and you don't have to actually
play the dictator game.
Now when you think about
distributional preferences,
what do distributional
preferences predict?
Well, dictators who want
to give some money strictly
prefer to play
the dictator game.
If you think you prefer
9-1 over 10-0 well,
then you're going
to play the game
and say I'm going to choose
9-1 because otherwise, there's
no way to actually
give this person money.
Notice distributional
preferences,
just to remind you,
are preferences
were only the outcomes matter.
It doesn't matter how
the outcomes come about.
Only the actual outcome matters.
Now there are some people who
want to just keep everything
to themselves.
Well, those people
who should just
be indifferent--
they will just be
like, it doesn't really
matter whether I just opt out.
Maybe that's easier to opt out.
It doesn't really matter.
I would give 10-0 anyway,
either opt out or just
stay in the game and
choose 10-0 anyway.
But in either case, the
option to exit the game
should have no effect on how
much the dictators share.
It shouldn't matter.
If you want to give
some positive amount,
if you opt that option,
it doesn't really
matter because you're
not going to opt out.
You're going to just opt in.
You stay in the game and just
give the money to that person.
And if you want
to give 0 anyway,
it doesn't matter whether
you opt out or not.
You just give 0 anyway,
and if you opt out,
it's essentially effectively
giving 0 to the other person.
So either way,
the option to exit
should have no effect on
how much dictators share.
In particular, it
should not reduce
how much dictators share.
Does that make sense?
OK.
The limited audience
seems to understand.
Hope this is clear to
everybody else as well.
By the way, I should have
said the lectures now
will be recorded currently
with a very limited audience,
but in general,
with no audience.
What I'm going to
do is try to keep
sort of what I very much
miss in this format is
sort of the interactive
form of the lectures.
So what are we're going to
do is trying to figure out,
in particular,
after spring break,
trying to record the
lectures and then finding
some other ways of allowing
students to interact, perhaps
by having a version
of, well, you
can watch the lectures
online, and then we
have essentially either online
office hours or discussions
of the slides.
Or if there are particular
issues that you may,
may answer some
questions over Zoom
or other formats we can then
discuss some issues that
perhaps aren't clear.
Or you can ask these
questions, and then I
try to respond to that.
Anyway, getting
back to this game,
essentially we have
now the comparison
between standard dictator
games and the option
of, in this case, a free exit.
So in this case, the exit
option lowers giving,
and the standard dictator game,
dictators shared about one euro
$0.87 on average.
That's, again, sort of
in line with the 20%, 25%
that people tend to give in
dictator games in the very
simplest form.
But when you allow people
to exit, the share given
goes down to $0.58.
OK?
And so that's essentially to
say there are many people who,
when they're getting
into the dictator game,
they feel compelled to give at
least some money because either
they feel bad
themselves somehow,
or they feel that the
other person will feel bad.
So you kind of want
to choose 10-0.
But you feel bad about the
other person feeling bad
if you choose 10-0, so you might
be inclined to choose 8-2, 7-3,
or the like.
Now if you allow the
costless exit option,
the person who in the
standard dictator game
would choose like 7-3,
6-4, or 8-2 or the like,
that person, in fact,
wants to choose the 10-0
but feels bad in the standard
dictator game, so chooses 7-3.
Once you allow
the costless exit,
the person just chooses the
10-0 and essentially, then,
by opting out, effectively
is choosing 10-0.
Now a different version of
this-- so what I showed you
so far was costless exit.
It essentially was free to exit.
You could just choose
the 10-0 and just run.
There was no cost of doing so.
The pie stayed the same.
There was no
subtraction of that.
Now different
versions of that games
were the exit is
actually costly.
That is to say, instead of
choosing a dictator game where
you can share 10 euros between
the dictator and the recipient,
now you can choose
the exit option.
You have to pay, essentially,
one euro for the exit option
so you get 9 euros if you exit,
and the other person still
gets 0.
So that's now to say people then
choose the costly exit, which
is to say they say, I'd
rather do the 9 euros
and not play the dictator
game with this other person.
Rather than playing
the dictator game
where you get 10
euros potentially,
you could choose 10 euros
and 0 for the other person.
But there seem to be quite a few
people who choose, essentially,
the costly exit, the 9 euros,
without playing the game.
And so they're here.
Say average subjects are
willing to take 82% of the pie
rather than split the full
pie in the dictator game.
That is to say
people essentially
are willing to forgo
quite a bit of money
to face the situation
where you have
to deal with this other person.
Notice that you could
choose exactly the same.
You could choose 10-0
or 9-0 or the like.
People don't want to do that.
Instead, they choose
the costly exit option
so the other person
never finds out.
So in some ways, you
don't have to deal
with yourself or the
other person feeling
bad about your not being nice.
And so that reveals,
in some sense,
saying if you see people
being nice in dictator games,
it seems to be, at
least to some degree,
that's not coming
from people generally
wanting to be nice
to the other person
and generally wanting to improve
people's payout for the sake
of making them richer.
But it's rather
they want to avoid
the other person
feels bad about them,
or getting mad or the like.
Now do let me just repeat that.
Why do people
subject want to exit?
Well, simply put, they want to
take the money for themselves,
but they don't want to indicate
to the potential recipient
that she's been
treated unfairly.
So exiting allows them
to satisfy their greed
and not to worry about the
participant's reaction.
Do you have any questions?
OK.
So that's the first
piece of evidence.
That's Lazear et al on costly
exit in a dictator game.
Now we discussed
already very last time
another version of
that, which essentially
is a different version,
which is providing excuses
or covers to be selfish.
This is a very nice paper
by Andreoni and Bernheim,
where essentially the
short summary of this
is what they do is they
allow for a computer option.
They allow for an option where
essentially, the computer
decides in some
cases, which gives
people cover to be not nice.
So if there's a chance that
you will decide yourself
and a chance that the computer
decides, and the recipient
doesn't know whether I chose
or the computer decided--
say it's 50% or the like--
I might choose a
very mean choice
because I can always say, well,
you know, I didn't do this.
It was the computer.
I wanted to be
really nice to you.
The computer happened
to be just mean.
Sorry about that.
I really tried to
be nice to you.
And so people essentially
use the computer as cover.
Let me show you what this
exact evidence looks like.
So this is a different version
of a non-anonymous dictator
game.
So this game is sort
of set up in a way
that you actually
know the other person,
so you have to sort of face
the other person, at least
in some way.
And so the way this is set up is
that the dictator's choice was
forced with some probability.
So this is a dictator
game with $20.
Now in the simplest version, the
computer chooses 20-0 or 0-20
with equal probability.
So if the computer
chooses, the computer
chooses either 20-0 or
0-20 with 50% chance each
if it's the computer's turn.
The dictator observes
the allocation
chosen by the computer.
The recipient does not.
If I'm the dictator, I can
see what the computer does,
and then I'm sort of
asked to make my choice.
The recipient does not know what
the computer actually chose.
The dictator then makes a
dictator game allocation
with a pie of $20
such as before.
Just happens to be
$20 rather than $10.
And the computer's
forced allocation
implemented with probability p
is known both to the dictator
and to recipient.
So the recipient knows
what the chance of p
is that I'm choosing versus
the computer choosing.
So the computer chooses
with probability p.
The dictator chooses with
probability 1 minus p.
That is known to both the
recipient and to the dictator.
And now the game will
vary the probability p.
So if the probability
p is like a 0,
if the computer never chooses,
and only the dictator chooses,
then we're back to the
typical dictator game.
Then I cannot hide
behind the computer.
It's obvious that I'm choosing.
If I'm choosing
20-0, you know that,
so I have no way of
blaming the computer.
If, in contrast, the
probability is larger than 0--
suppose the probability
is 50%, 60%, 70%--
it's very likely that
the computer chose.
So now I can also choose 20-0
and just say, well, sorry,
it happens to be that
the computer implemented
this choice.
Sorry that you got 0.
So I can essentially
hide behind the computer.
And the larger the
probability p is,
the more credible is this
hiding behind the computer
because you know if the
chance is only 5% or 10%,
you might not believe me that
the computer actually chose.
You're like, yeah,
yeah, Frank, you're
telling me it was the computer.
Really it was you.
But if the chance
is 90% or the like,
then it's actually very
likely, very plausible
that the computer
chose the main outcome.
And then I might also just
choose the mean outcome
because you're never
going to find out.
You're not going to suspect
that this was me as opposed
to the computer.
And then at the
end, the recipient
only learns the allocation,
not the dictator's choice.
The recipient only
learns what they get.
They do not learn what I
chose or whether it was
the computer or me who chose.
They only know the probability
p with which the computer or I
made that choice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does the
dictator know p
before he makes his allocation?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
So exactly.
The dictator knows p.
The dictator even knows,
I think, the actual choice
that the computer made, yeah.
But that's key here.
So both the dictator and
the recipient know p.
That's really important because
only if I know what p is,
I can actually react
to it and hide.
So the prediction
here will be that if p
is very high, if the computer
chooses with high probability,
people will be more likely
to be mean in the 10-0 case
because I could just
essentially emulate the computer
and hide behind it.
But for that I need to
know exactly what p is.
So now what do distributional
preferences here predict?
Again, distributional
preferences
are preferences such that you
only care about the outcome.
You don't care about
how this came about.
So the dictator here should
only think about the case
in which her choice counts.
That is to say, the computer
is entirely irrelevant
because again, I can't influence
what the computer does anyway.
It doesn't matter whether the
computer chooses with 5% or 10%
or a 20% chance, or
50%, even 70% chance.
The only thing I
should care about
is well, for the chance of 1
minus p when I choose myself,
what am I going to do?
And what are my
distributional preferences?
How much do I want to give
you versus the other person?
And that's essentially
the only case
in which she can, in fact,
affect the distribution.
And so p should have essentially
no effect in people's choices.
So that's a very
straightforward prediction.
Essentially, you only
care about the case
when you can make a difference.
And in that case,
you just choose
whatever you want to choose
between 20-0 and 0-20,
whatever you want to
give the other person.
The other cases are just
irrelevant because they are out
of the person's control.
Now why might p matter anyway?
I already said that.
Essentially p might
matter because you
can hide behind the computer
if p is particularly high.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the recipient
knows that the computer can only
choose 20 or 0?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There's different
versions of that, exactly.
Exactly.
In some case, the computer
could choose 20-0,
0-20 with equal probability.
So the recipient knows that.
That's known.
AUDIENCE: If it's like a
80-20 and the recipient
knows automatically.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
That's exactly right.
I'm going to show you
exactly that evidence.
In fact, what the
game will do is--
sorry.
The question was
does the recipient
know whether it's 20-0 versus
18-two or something else?
And that's exactly right.
The only plausible way in which
I can hide behind the computer,
in this case, is if I want
to be selfish, is 20-0.
If I choose 19-one,
you know it was me.
It can't end up in the computer
because the computer can only
do 20-0-0-20.
And that's key here.
And there's going to
be some variation.
And that variation will
really what the computer does.
And essentially
that will exactly
reveal people hiding
behind the computer
because then some variation
will be the computer does 19-1,
and suddenly people
choose a lot of 19-1.
And the only reason
why you might do that
is exactly because
you might want
to hide behind the computer.
So let me show you that,
exactly that, in fact.
So here's now what we find.
This is a bit of a
complicated graph
so let me try to walk you
through that in detail.
So the graph shows
you the following.
It shows you on the y-axis
the fraction that people gave,
on, average for, the
different scenarios.
So how much, what
percentage of the $20
did the person give
to the other person,
decide the dictator to do?
This is not the computer.
So this is only the
dictator's choices.
On the x-axis, we
see the probability
of the forced choice,
of x 0 being 0.
This is essentially to say
what is the forced choice?
What is the chance that
the other person gets 0?
The computer chooses with
some probability 20-0,
so 20 for the dictator and
0 for the other person,
and that's happening for
different probability.
So the probability is
either 0, 25%, 50%, or 75%.
That's the p that I
mentioned earlier.
Let's look at p equals
0% to start with.
That's essentially
the scenario in which
the computer is irrelevant.
The computer never
makes any choices.
What you see, essentially,
is the typical behavior
in dictator games.
Sorry, I should have also
mentioned that here's much,
then the different
lines are, like how much
is given to the other person.
So the blue line that
you see there is like 10.
That's the 10-10 allocation.
How much is the dictator
giving to the other person?
The red line is a 0.
This is essentially
the 20-0 allocation.
And the other two lines
down there are 1, 2 to 9,
and there's also larger than 10.
What we're going to
focus on is essentially
how often does
the person give 0,
and how often does the
person give, like, 50%?
So when you look at the 0%
line, essentially, that's
the typical dictator choice.
Again, p is 0.
The computer is
entirely irrelevant.
The computer can't do anything.
Now I cannot hide
behind the computer.
You get sort of the typical
dictator game outcomes.
But just, like, 55% of people,
actually, more than usual,
give half.
They choose the
10-10 allocation.
About 30% of people choose 0.
That's very common.
And then there are some people
below that give either 2 to 9,
or 1 or even larger than 10.
So that's typically what
we see in a dictator game.
Now moving to the right
is now positive p's.
This is p equals
0.25%, 50%, 75%.
And now what we're
seeing, essentially,
is that as you
move to the right,
in particular going from
0 to 25 and from 25 to 50,
the probability of, or
the fraction of people
who choose 0 for the other
person goes up quite a bit.
So now, for example, look at
the 50% chance equals 50%.
Now there's a 50% chance that
the other person gets 0 anyway
because the computer chose so.
And now, if I'm the
dictator, essentially I
can also choose 20-0.
And we know once you, as a
recipient, see the outcome,
you cannot tell if it was a
50% chance that it was me,
it was a 50% chance it was
the computer choosing that.
And so in that case, you
see now that 70% of people
actually choose 20-0.
So that fraction goes up from
30% for p equals 0 to about 50%
for p equals 25%, and
to 70% for p equals 50%.
So essentially, the larger p
is, at least for the range of 0
to 50%, the larger
is the fraction
of people who actually
choose the 20-0 allocation,
presumably because it's
now more plausible if I'm
hiding behind the computer.
Now you see for
people, 75%, now there
seems to be sort of
no increase anymore.
It's a little unclear
how to interpret that.
To some degree, this could be
because now, 50% is already
large enough.
That's already very plausible
that the computer chose anyway,
so going from 50 to 75,
there's no additional benefits
of hiding behind the computer.
It could also be that
people in some way sort
feel bad for the other
person because there's
a high chance that they get
0 anyway from the computer.
So you might as well give
something to that other person,
perhaps.
I'm not quite sure, but that's,
in some sense, not the point
here.
The point here is that
the fraction who are mean
goes up by a lot when you
can hide behind the computer.
The fraction who
looks or is quite
nice who chooses
the 10-10 allocation
goes down by quite a bit.
Does that make sense?
And the following slides
have added a fairly detailed
description of this.
But let's pause for a second to
see whether that makes sense.
So I think I have
already said all of this.
This is to say, the
higher p star or p is,
the easier it is
for the dictator
to hide behind the computer.
I said all of that already.
So when you sort of take
together this evidence,
it seems to be evidence
that people are not
as nice as results from
simple dictator games
might suggest because,
in some sense,
in the simple
dictator games, they
would like to do something
else, but they just can't really
do so.
And this is kind of
like your question here.
This is a very nice
variation that they have.
This is a different variation
where the computer now chooses
19-1 with probability p.
So the computer essentially
chooses 19 for the dictator
and 1 for the other person
with probability, again,
p equals 0, 25%, 50%, 75%.
And exactly as you sort of
predicted and thought about,
is you see the same thing
happening for the people
choosing 10.
That fraction goes down.
But instead, people are not
now choosing more of 20-0.
Instead, what they're
choosing-- in fact,
there's a fraction of
people that choose 20-0.
The red line goes down a bit.
Instead, what goes up
is the 19-1 allocation.
So lots of people now
choose 19 for themselves
and 1 for the other person.
Why is that?
It's because now you can
hide between the 19-1 choice
of the computer.
And that's the selfish choice.
The 20-0 choice, in fact,
goes down a little bit,
perhaps because it becomes quite
obvious that these are people
who are quite selfish anyway.
But now they choose
the 19-1 option.
They switch to 19-1 because
now, you're kind of mean anyway,
but now you can essentially
hide behind the computer.
OK?
Any questions on this?
So now what's going on here?
So one potential explanation
is face-saving concerns,
essentially social image.
So these are the motivation
to avoid unfavorable judgment
by others.
It's essentially if
you care about what
others think about
you, you might
engage in certain behaviors.
So the experiment
provides a way to provide
people to avoid such judgments.
So remember, this is
not an anonymous game.
You have to face
this other person
and deal with them afterwards,
at least in some way.
So now, essentially, the
experiment, the computer
provides, essentially, people
an opportunity to save face,
and essentially to keep
up their social image
because essentially, what
you're trying to avoid here
is if you choose the 20-0
option the other person will
think you're not very nice.
And either you're
trying to avoid to have
to see that they're unhappy.
You might just feel bad about
them if they're unhappy.
Or perhaps more plausible,
it just feels bad for you
if other people think
you're kind of mean.
So you want to be
mean, but you don't
want others to
think you're mean,
and therefore you hide
behind the computer.
I think I said all
of this already.
So both of these
types of evidence,
I think, the exit in
the dictator game,
but also the evidence
that I showed you
just now, hiding
behind the computer,
seems to say when there's an
option to avoid people feeling
bad or people feeling
that you're mean to them,
people tend to take that option,
and then essentially, that
reduces their giving behavior.
Now in some sense, when you
think about many other--
and there's some empirical
evidence on this by Gautam Rao
and Stefano
DellaVigna and others,
in a situation when it comes
to voting or other gift-giving
choices overall, people are
willing to pay, essentially,
to avoid situations where
they're asked to give.
This is like somebody comes
to your door and says,
would you like to
donate for this cause,
or would you like to
vote for this candidate,
and so on and so forth.
People might, once they ask
them, I'd say, yeah, sure,
I'll do it because
they feel bad,
or it feels like it's not
a very-- so [INAUDIBLE]
shows you pictures
of poor children
and some terrible situations.
If you are now saying, no, I
don't want to give any money,
you look like a
really mean person.
So what people
then tend to do is
they tend to essentially just
avoid the situation altogether
by either pretending
that they're not home
or indicating never
opening the door.
Or if you see somebody
on the street who
wants to collect
donations, you might just
essentially avoid that person
altogether, go out of your way.
If you see a beggar
on the street,
you essentially might
go around that person
because you try to avoid,
essentially, judgment,
either feeling bad for them
about you being mean to them,
or feeling bad about them just
judging you in certain ways
for not being a nice person.
How do we think about this
in terms of utility function?
We're not going to talk
about this very much.
We're going to get
into this a little bit
back about this when
you talk about beliefs
and belief-based utility.
But just to give
you a sense of how
to think about this in terms of
modeling it, so what you need,
essentially, is
like another term.
And utility function-- in
addition to your distributional
preferences about you put some
weight on how much you get
and how much the
other person gets--
you need some other term--
I call it v--
which is player 1's
beliefs about rho.
Like what does the other
person think that your rho is?
So if you really don't
want to give anything
to that other person,
you want to avoid
that the other person thinks
that you put very little weight
on the other person.
So rho, again, to remind
you, is the weight
that's put on the other person.
This is the perspective
of player 2.
So rho is the weight that
you put on the other person.
And now essentially,
player 2 might
put some weight on player
1 in terms of the output
that they get.
They want to give
them some money,
and if they have more
money, they feel happier.
But they also put
some weight on what
player 1 thinks that my rho is.
So if I have the choice,
do I want to give 10?
If I have $10, and I can
choose that in a dictator game
to give it to the other person,
I might want to do 10-0,
and that's essentially
just coming from my rho.
But I also don't
want the other person
to think that my rho is 0.
So I might derive
positive utility
from the other player thinking
that my rho is whatever, 0.3,
0.5, or whatever.
I like that the other
person thinks that I'm
of a positive weight on them.
And therefore, I
might give them more.
More generally, I guess you can
just sort of have the utility
function that depends on
the other person's outputs
or on each person's
outcome, how much they get,
and on the other's beliefs about
what my utility function looks
like.
So essentially,
people care about
whether others think
that they are nice
or have concerns for others
in the utility function.
Again, we're not going to
talk about this in more
detail, at least for now.
We're going to get back to this
when we think about beliefs
and belief-based utility,
which essentially
is the idea that beliefs
are potentially not
just instrumental, but
about like others usually
help you make good decisions.
But it might be that you
also just derive utility
from beliefs.
You might drive utility
from thinking that you're
smart, good-looking, and so on.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So now one question
you might have,
and I already
alluded to that, is
are people giving because
they enjoy giving,
or because it's uncomfortable
refusing to give?
is?
It like, I really want to
give and I feel really good
about it.
I get some warm
glow in some ways.
Or is it in some ways, I'm
giving not because I actually
enjoy it and I'm happy about it,
but rather, because otherwise
I just feel bad
and uncomfortable.
So the evidence we
talked about suggests
that the latter motivation
is more important for many.
So many people kind of just
feel bad by not giving.
This is essentially in
particular, the evidence
that people are willing to pay
to avoid dictator games that I
showed you.
There's a very nice
paper about what's
called moral wiggle room,
which gets at the idea
that in a way, if people opt
out of the dictator game,
they have to justify to
themselves that they're mean.
So if you have
self-image, if you also
care about how do you
think about yourself,
are you a good
person or not, how
do you justify to
yourself, essentially,
that you chose a 20-0 option.
And the Dana et al paper
is a very nice paper
that sort of illustrates
that very nicely.
So this is, again,
a very simple game.
Subjects are asked to
choose between self, other.
So how much do you get
yourself and how much
does the other person get?
There's two options here.
Option A is you get $6.00
for yourself and x dollars
for the other person.
Option B is you get $5.00
for yourself and y dollars
for the other person.
And x and y is varied
across subjects
subject and randomized.
So one option here is x
equals 1 and y equals 5.
Now what does that mean
for Options A and B?
That means option A is,
if you had to choose,
would be 6 for yourself
and 1 for the other person.
Option B is like
5 for each player.
So now choosing between
Option B and Option A.
If you choose Option
A, essentially,
you get $1.00 more than you
would get if you chose Option B
But the other person gets $4.00
less than they would get if you
chose Option B. So choosing
Option A is not a particularly
nice option.
Essentially you decide that one
additional dollar for you is
worth more than $4.00 that
the other person gets less.
And so again, that's
not a very nice move.
So most people, in fact,
tend to choose Option B when
faced with that direct choice.
That is to say, 26%
of people choose
Option A. They choose the
selfish option, if you want.
And 74% choose Option B,
which is, in some ways,
the nice thing to do.
This is the very
standard version of it.
There's no other
things going on.
There's no exit
option and so on.
And so again, I said all this.
So now when people
choose Option B,
there's essentially
two explanations here.
One is the person is quite nice.
The other explanation is in some
ways, they're not that nice,
but they're just trying
to avoid feeling bad.
They kind of want
to choose Option A,
but if you choose Option A,
you feel really bad about it,
and that's why you don't do it.
Now the game also has
a twist here, which
is for some other subjects--
these are some subjects
just had this choice only.
They choose, as
I said, 74% chose
Option B. Some other
subjects, x and y
were initially
unknown with either x
equals 1 and y equals 5, or
x equals 5 and y equals 1.
And those are implemented
with 50% chance.
So initially you don't know.
It could be either--
let me just write this down.
Could be one of two scenarios.
Both the chance 50%.
So one of them is if you choose
Option A, that's the choice
that we just had before.
The first one is Option A versus
B. That's what we just had,
which essentially
is 6-1 versus 5-5.
So their choosing A is
a pretty selfish move.
That's the option
I just showed you.
The second scenario is
it's 6-5 versus 5-1.
Now it's unambiguously clear
that you should choose Option
A because you're better off,
the other person is better off,
everybody is happy.
So surely you should choose
Option A. Essentially
Option A dominates Option
B in the second scenario.
OK?
Now here's the twist.
Subjects could costlessly find
out which one is the case.
And the recipient, in
this case, will not
learn what the other person did.
The recipient just essentially
receives the money.
The recipient does not
know what the person does.
So now, essentially, I
will tell you there's
two scenarios going
on, either one or two.
I'm going to ask you
to choose A versus B.
And you have two options
before that choice.
The option is either you can
just choose without not knowing
which scenario you're in,
or you can choose costlessly
to find out whether you're
in Choice 1 versus Choice 2.
OK.
So is that easy
to set up, clear?
Happy to repeat.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Who is
choosing between 1 and 2?
PROFESSOR: So if
you're in the game,
there's a 50% chance that you're
in scenario 1 and a 50% chance
in scenario 2.
That is fixed.
You have two choices to
make in your whole decision.
The first one is, do you want
to find out whether you're
in scenario 1 or in scenario 2?
So either you don't find
out-- it's just a 50% chance
of scenario 1 and 50%
chance of scenario 2--
or you find out costlessly
I'm going to tell you
you're in scenario
1 or scenario 2.
It's already decided
which scenario you're in.
You just don't know it.
So your first choice
is do you want
to know which
scenario you're in?
The second choice, then,
is between A and B.
And you either choose
without knowing
what scenario you're in.
You're either in 1 or 2.
You choose A and
B, and then it's
just going to be
implemented afterwards,
the A or B for each
of the scenarios,
or the one that's
actually implemented.
Or you know already you're
in scenario 1 or scenario 2
because you
costlessly found out,
and then you make that
choice about A and B.
Does it make sense?
OK.
Perfect.
So now first, we can think about
distributional preferences.
What happens if you just
have purely distributional
preferences?
Could this additional
twist in any way
lower people's giving behavior?
And so when you are
distributional preferences,
notice that what I added--
so what we're comparing here is
only having the first scenario
to choose.
We're comparing
that to the twist.
So we're comparing,
essentially, this scenario--
this is the people who
chose without having
this additional twist going on.
We're going to compare
those kinds of people
to people who are randomized
to have this additional twist,
where they first have
the choice or the option
to costlessly find
out where they are.
And the question
I'm going to ask
is, now, how does adding
this additional option affect
people's giving behavior?
And in particular,
is it possible
that people give less because of
adding this additional choice?
So now there's two
options overall.
Either it's the case
that your optimal choice
depends on x and y--
so either you're going
to tell me, well,
whether I choose A or
B depends on x and y.
And if that's the
case, well, of course
then you want to find
out what x and y is.
Remember, what is x and y?
X and y is the thing
that I have at the top.
X and y is either x
equals 1 and y equals 5,
or it is x equals
5 and y equals 1.
So it either is the case
that it matters to you
what x and y are--
either you really want
to find out what x and y is.
Well, in that case,
surely if I ask you,
do you want to
costlessly find out,
you don't want to
find out because you
want to make the right choice.
You want to know,
am I in scenario 1
or am I in scenario 2?
So then if I offer you
the costless option
to find out which
scenario you're in,
but you want to find out.
And then if you find out
that you're in the x equals 1
and y equals 5 situation, you
should make the same choice
that you chose previously.
If you chose previously
Option A or Option
B, once you find out
what scenario you're in,
surely you're going to choose
the same thing because you only
care about distributiona;
preferences.
You're going to just
choose the same thing.
Now if your choice,
on the other hand,
does not depend on
x and y, you should
be indifferent between
finding out or not.
And it shouldn't really
matter whether they give you
that option, in some sense.
You should choose the same
thing as you chose before.
In either case, when x
equals 1 and y equals 5,
leaving x and y
initially unknown,
so adding this
additional option,
should not decrease
the amount of giving.
If anything, it should not
be affected in any case.
But in particular, it
should not decrease it.
So let me have you look
at this for a second
just to be clear on that.
So essentially
what I'm saying is
adding this additional
thing, the scenario 2,
either the scenarios
matter, and if the scenarios
matter whether you're in
scenario 1 versus scenario
2, if you make different
choices, well, then
surely you should find out
which scenario you're in.
And you're going to say,
OK, I really want to know.
Once you know whether
you're in scenario 1--
suppose you're actually
in scenario 1--
you should make the same
choice as you did before.
And if you say, well,
I actually don't
care which scenario I'm in.
I'm going to make the
same choice anyway,
then adding this
additional scenario
shouldn't really matter
anyway because you
choose the same thing anyway.
But regardless, adding
essentially the scenario 2
should not decrease
how much you give.
Now what they find
instead is 44%
chose not to find out x and y.
And of these subjects,
95% chose Option A.
So these are people
who essentially they
say, I'd rather not know
what's going on here,
then they chose Option A,
which is either the fairly
selfish option, or
it's the option that's
better for both people.
Let me go back to
this so you see this.
So when given these two
choices, they essentially say,
I'd rather not know, even
if it's costless to do.
I don't want to know whether
I'm in scenario 1 or 2.
I'm going to choose Option
A. Why do they do that,
or what's going
on in their minds?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: They don't
want to know if they're
being mean to the other person.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So if you find out whether
it's scenario 1 or scenario 2,
things can happen.
One will be you'll be
in scenario number 2.
You're going to choose
Option A because you know
that's better for everybody.
Or you're going to
be in scenario 1,
well, then, choosing A is kind
of a selfish and mean move.
And then, once you do that, then
you have to sort of deal with,
well, am I a mean person or not?
Instead, what people do or
seem to do, is they just say,
I actually don't
want to find out.
It could be either way.
Who knows what's going on?
Could be scenario 1,
could be scenario 2.
Who knows?
But you know, there's
a good chance,
50% chance that it's scenario 2,
in which case choosing Option A
is actually good for everybody.
So let me just not find out
and then choose Option A,
and I'm going to essentially
make myself think that,
oh, probably it was
scenario number 2.
So essentially what
people are doing here
is they sort of delude
themselves in some way
into thinking that they're
doing the right thing,
or they're doing not a mean
thing by avoiding information
that would essentially be free.
So if you really wanted to find
out whether you're mean or not,
you could just get
the information.
And since it's like free
there and entirely available.
Instead, what people
do is they just say,
oh, I'd rather not
know, and then they
choose the thing that's
at least potentially mean.
And so then not only is it
the case that 44% of people
choose not to find out, but also
the fraction of selfish people
goes up by a lot.
So I showed you--
this is a little bit
tricky-- but essentially
what I showed you here is
that there's a 50% chance
to be in scenario 1
versus in scenario 2.
And the 63% that I'm
going to show you here,
this is the fraction
who essentially
chose the selfish choice.
This is only looking at
the 50% chance for which x
equals 1 and y equals 5.
So essentially this
is taking the half
of the cases in
which, actually, x
equals 1 and y equals
5 was implemented.
These are cases where either
the person found out or not.
But when you take
those things together--
so these are like essentially
two scenarios or the sum of two
things that happened--
one is the person didn't find
out and chose Option A or B,
or the person
actually found out.
But taken together, essentially
63% of people in those cases
chose the selfish
option, Option A,
compared to the 26%
in the baseline case
that I showed you earlier.
So putting these things
together essentially
means that there's
quite a few people who
conveniently don't want to
find out whether they're mean
or not.
They choose, then,
the mean option,
and much more so than when
they don't have this whole--
what's called moral wiggle room,
which essentially is the option
to delude themselves,
and they're actually not
that mean because
probably, it was better
for everybody to choose Option
A. Does that make sense?
So now you might ask two things.
Well, it could be that
there's this concern
about others' beliefs.
This could be
about social image,
or could be about self-image.
Now the experiment is
precisely set up in a way
that, in fact, it's
not about social image.
The other person, in
fact, doesn't find out
whether you learned her payoff.
And so not learning doesn't
really help improve her.
The other person
only sees the result.
So whether I actually learn
about which scenario we're in
doesn't really actually help
improving the other person's
opinion.
The only person who actually
knows whether you found out
what scenario you're
in is actually you
yourself when you make
that choice, which
really suggests that this
is about saving face, about
self-image.
People essentially want to
delude themselves or make
themselves think that they're
nicer than they actually
are by avoiding information
that could actually help them
make the right choice or
be nicer if they really
wanted to be.
So if you really wanted to
be nice, what you would do
is you would really find out
which scenario you're in.
You would choose
Option A and Scenario 2
when it's better for everybody,
and you choose option B
if it's better for
the other person
or really costly for the other
person to choose Option A.
So let me sort of
summarize here.
So the most likely
explanation is
that it's really
based on how dictators
feel about themselves.
So the uncertainty in
whether the selfish action
helps or hurts the other person
gives an excuse to be selfish.
So now I can say, oh,
50% chance that this is
the right choice for everybody.
So that's an excuse.
So you can keep telling yourself
that you didn't mean any harm.
I really didn't want to be mean.
I thought with a good
chance the other person will
be better off as well.
And this term is sort of
called moral wiggle room, which
essentially is
sort of helping you
be in an ambiguous situation
because once you haven't found
out, it's actually unclear
whether the other person is
better off or worse off by
choosing Option A and B.
The experiment is
set up in a way
that if you do not find out
which scenario you're in,
it's not clear what's better
for the other person what
to choose.
But of course, that's
amazing in some sense
because you could always
find out costlessly.
And sometimes you can
delude yourself and say, ah,
it's not clear.
What should we do?
I don't know.
Could be good for the
person, bad for the person,
whatever, but I'm choosing A.
But of course that's silly
because in some sense
that's not an explanation that
holds water because you could
always find out, if you
really wanted to know,
whether you wanted to be
nice to the other person.
It's very easy to find
out what's going on.
So that's essentially
to say people
want to save face in
front of themselves
as opposed to in
front of others.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So now a different
version of that is giving
and communication, which,
is, again in some ways,
about social image
concerns, about having
to deal with others'
reactions to you.
This could be about
self-image or social image.
But either way, it's about
some form of communication,
how others or you yourself feel.
So Ellingsen and Johannesson
modified the dictator game
by allowing for a very
limited form of communication.
One group of subjects played
the usual dictator game,
which is just as usual.
And the other group,
the recipients
only were allowed to
send anonymous messages
to the dictator after
receiving their share.
Is that the version you played,
or was it different for you?
Could you already
talk to them earlier,
when there was communication?
It might have been the exact
version that you played,
or it might have
been in your version,
you could actually talk to
the other person earlier.
AUDIENCE: You could only
message before you decided.
PROFESSOR: I see.
So that's a slightly different
version from what you played.
This one is a version where the
recipient could only respond.
So the dictator gets the
$10 or whatever is played.
The dictator makes a choice,
and then the recipient
can essentially
send a message back,
can in some way
reciprocate if you want.
Could be a nice message if
you give quite a bit of money,
or it could be a mean message if
you didn't give a lot of money.
And anticipating that might
affect the dictator's choices.
And so this is kind of what
they found in the paper.
So essentially, the
anticipation of a feedback
increased sharing from 25%
to 34% in this specific game.
That's quite a bit.
So most recipients, in fact,
do choose to send a message.
The messages vary quite a bit.
So it's about very
mean messages saying,
so you chose to take
all the money yourself,
you greedy bastard.
I was just wondering if there
was anyone who would do that.
And the answer is
apparently yes.
Apparently people
like you exist.
Have a nice evening.
So that's not a
very nice message.
I also censored a few messages
that were in there earlier.
Another one is, thank
you, greedy bastard.
You will like it as
investment banker.
I hope you will
buy something nice.
And then there's sort
of positive messages,
presumably, when people are
actually given quite a bit
of money, which is like,
there's hope for a better world.
With the help of your
generosity and your big heart,
I can tonight break the
black pudding curse.
No more pea soup.
You have a standing invitation
to dinner at my place.
The door is always
open with love.
So you know that
varies by quite a bit.
And anticipating those
kinds of messages,
you can see how
dictators then might,
particularly if they play
this repeatedly and have
some experience with it,
might opt into giving more.
So this indicates that
sort of beyond caring
about the recipient's
reaction, dictators
care how shielded
they are from it.
So it's not just
about, you might
feel bad-- so what I showed you
previously in the costless exit
thing, it was more about I'm
worried about you feeling bad,
and I don't want you to feel
bad even if I don't have
to face you in any situations.
This one is about, I might
worry about you feeling bad,
but I also might
worry about receiving
that message from you.
So there are some people
who might actually
be fine about the other person
feeling bad as long as I
don't have to face it.
But now, if I actually
have to face the message
from the other person, I might
behave nicer in some ways
because I didn't have to
actually deal with the fact
or face the fact that perhaps
I'm not a nice person.
In our version--
I looked this up--
it seems like there's not
much evidence of communication
affecting behavior.
This could be, perhaps, because
the version with communication
was different from
what was played here.
So it doesn't seem like
once the person gave,
I think the game was
just over, as opposed
to once the person gave, you
could send a message back
and reciprocate in some way.
So here you can see that.
In a dictator game
without communication,
notice that the axes are
changing a little bit.
This is like the monetary
stakes, no communication.
This is with communication.
Notice that the axis changes.
I can't really fix
this from the software,
but if you look at the average
offer, with no communication,
it's 38%.
With communication, it's
37%, so if anything,
it's a little bit lower.
The comparison is a little
bit unclean because over time,
maybe later in the
game, you play different
than earlier in the
game, and it's not quite
cleanly randomized.
But it doesn't
seem, in your case,
like the communication
mattered very much.
Again, perhaps that's because
the nature of the game
is somewhat different.
Sorry.
This is actually
not a dictator game.
This is the ultimatum game.
This is a typo at the top.
For the ultimatum game, it
seems like communication matters
a little bit when
you look at this.
When you look at the very
left, people giving 0,
for whatever reason, I don't
know how you communicated
and what you said, but it seems
like your communication made
people more likely
to give 0, and then
these 0 options being rejected.
So this is what you see on the
very left is in the ultimatum
game, the red is
essentially, these
are offers that are rejected.
Without communication,
nobody was giving 0.
With communication, somehow
people are giving 0,
and then these
offers were rejected.
So perhaps some of you gave very
negative messages or threats
or whatever, and that
really pissed off
the dictator, the other
person, and then essentially
that really backfired.
So I don't know who is teaching
you how to communicate,
but maybe you want to think
about this in future games.
Somehow communication,
if anything,
made things worse compared
to the no communication case.
But even there, if you
look at the average offer
is 47% here on the top.
And again, 46%
with communication.
So it doesn't make a huge
difference either way.
OK?
Any questions on that?
So then we're going
to talk a little bit
about intentions-based
social preferences.
Let me tell you a
brief tale about this
that sort of illustrates
this point quite nicely.
So a boy finds two ripe apples
as he walks home from school.
He keeps the larger one, gives
a smaller one to his friend.
The friend says, it wasn't
nice to keep the larger one.
The boy says, well, what
would you have done?
And the friend says, I'd
have given you the larger one
and kept the smaller one.
And the boy says, well, we
each got what you wanted.
So what are you
complaining about?
And so what does
that illustrate?
It illustrates that
it's not always
about outcomes or the
distribution, even,
of outcomes or the like.
What seems to
matter is some form
of like justice or fairness in
how the allocation came about.
In most of the economics,
essentially, we
assume that our
satisfaction of outcomes,
like how much we like certain
outcomes and so on, when
you look at people's utility
function, often, essentially,
it's outcome-based.
What matters is essentially how
much you consume, and so on.
So the satisfaction
with outcomes
doesn't depend on how
the outcome came about.
And here, when you
look at these apples,
how the apples are distributed,
the friend actually
doesn't seem to care that
much about whether he
gets the larger or
the smaller apple.
What the friend cares about
is, is your other friend
a nice person, or is the
allocation of the outcome fair,
and a sense of didn't
he just keep the larger
apple because he could, and
then was mean to his friend.
So really what seems to
matter quite a bit is--
and there's quite a bit of
work in organizational behavior
and economics and
social psychology--
is the idea of
procedural justice.
Fairness in the process
used to allocate resources
seems to matter quite a bit.
So maybe another
way to put this,
it's kind of OK,
actually, for most people.
If some people are richer
than others that's fine,
but it's much less if
they obtained money
as coming in some
corrupt process,
or if it's just kind of unfair
because some person was born
really rich, and the other
person was born really poor,
and there's no mobility
or opportunity in society.
That's sort of relating
to the idea that in a way,
the American dream is
everybody can become rich,
and that's essentially
the key here.
And then if some people
are richer than others,
people often think that's OK.
What's not OK, however,
is if some people
have vastly different
opportunities or chances
than others.
Or if there's lots of
corruption, where essentially
some people get certain jobs
not because they're qualified,
but rather because their
parents or their family
or their friends or
whatever are very powerful
or they have corrupted
others in other ways.
Now there's a
question of fairness,
and then there's a
question of reciprocity,
which is essentially the idea
that so fairness, people have
preferences for fairness.
They like fair outcomes more
than others, unfair outcomes.
Another form of
that is reciprocity,
is people like to treat
others as others have treated
or treating them.
More generally, the way we treat
others, essentially, depends
on the way they treat us.
So if somebody is
mean to you, you're
going to be mean to them.
If somebody is
nice to you, you're
going to be nice to them.
And that's really
important motivation
in a lot of behavior.
Now this gets us back
to the ultimatum game--
I'm going to talk about
this only very briefly--
which is the question of why
do responders reject low offers
in the ultimatum game?
We talked about
this a little bit.
You can think about
distributional preferences.
We talked about [INAUDIBLE] and
Rabin and about the preferences
about being behind versus not.
There's an explanation
that's based
on distributional
preference where you just
don't want to be really
behind, and therefore you
reject the unfair offers.
But another one is you think
you've really treated unfairly,
and you're willing to punish the
proposer for such unfairness.
And in a simple
ultimatum game, you
can't really tell whether
it's hypothesis one or two.
But-- and we talked
about this already--
you can compare responders'
choices in the ultimatum game
to choices when the
offer isn't generated
by the other person, the
recipient or the other person.
For example, you
can look at choices
that were generated by the
computer, by a third person
and so on.
So if it's generated by the
third person, you might say,
I shouldn't punish the
other person in the game
because it's not that
person who chose it.
It's some other person,
so it's not their fault.
So why should I punish them?
Similarly, if the
computer chose, again,
if I have less than the other
person, that might be OK.
I might not be happy
about it, but it's not
the other person's fault.
It's the computer who chose.
In the next lecture, we're
going to talk about a field
application of that.
It's a very nice paper by
Emily Breza and co-authors,
which is about the morale
effects of pay inequality.
This is about how workers
behave in a work environment
when people are paid unequally.
And the short summary of this
paper is that when workers--
this is a field
experiment in India--
when workers are paid unequally,
they might be really unhappy
and be less productive at
their work because essentially,
and particularly if
they have to collaborate
with other workers who
are paid more than them.
But in particular, what
they seem to care about
is, is it fair that the
other person earns more?
So if you earn
more than I do, it
might actually be OK
if I can understand
that you are much
smarter, faster,
or better at what you do.
So if in some
observable ways, I can
tell that you're better than
I am, then, in some sense,
I might be perfectly
fine with you
earning like 10%, 20%,
50% or whatever percent
more money because I know
you're a better worker.
So OK, fine, you're paid more.
That seems fine and OK.
However, in some
other situation where
it's kind of not that obvious,
where it looks like you're
doing the same
thing that I'm doing
and not really faster
or better and so on,
yet you're paid more, I might
be really annoyed and unhappy
about it.
And you might also
be uncomfortable
because you feel bad about being
paid more than I do for doing
exactly the same thing.
So the experiment by
Emily Breza and coauthors
is doing exactly that, looking
at situations where workers are
paid unequally versus the
same, and situations where this
is justified versus
not, and really
seems to be that fairness
matters, or perceived fairness
matters quite a bit
for these workers.
When workers can justify being
paid less in some way, or more
than others, that's OK.
When it's unjustified,
they really
get annoyed and
produce a lot less
in that particular setting.
OK.
So let me now start with
some field evidence.
We're going to talk a lot more
about field evidence next time.
Let me briefly talk about this
paper here, and the next time,
I'm going to tell you
a lot more about that.
So this is a very nice paper
by Bandiera et al which
looks at the impact of
relative pay versus piece rates
on productivity.
Piece rates is just like
whatever you produce,
you're going to be paid
by unit of your output.
You just get some fixed
payment per each unit of output
that you produce.
Relative pay is
essentially your workers
are paid relative to others.
So if I'm working
50% more than you do,
I get paid a lot
more than you do.
Now why does this matter
for people, worker behavior?
Well, there's a
negative externality now
on me working really hard.
What's an externality?
Essentially an effect
on you that you're not
really compensated for.
That is to say, if
I worked really hard
and I'm really good at
my work, not only am
I getting paid more,
but also you're
going to be paid less because
essentially relatively,
you're going to
look worse than me
if you work in the same team.
So relative pay
essentially has this issue
about where it matters
for social preferences
because essentially,
any increase in my pay
comes at a reduction
of your pay.
To be clear, the
relative pay is such
that there's an
average pay which
depends on the average
productivity of everybody.
And then the relative
pay is on top of that,
is like the workers
who work more,
are more productive
relative to others,
are paid more than others.
And so how do you
think about this?
You can think about a
model of pure altruism.
We talked about
this already before.
There's self has a payoff of x.
The other person has a
payoff of x0 for other.
The self assigns weight alpha
to the other person's utility.
This is sort of the
typical model that's
been used by Becker and others.
We don't really
think that's really
the right model for
many situations,
but it's a really
useful benchmark model.
And so now, if I have positive
weight on this other person,
what I'm going to
do is I'm going to,
in the relative pay
scheme, I might not
work particularly
hard because I know
if I'm working really hard, I'm
going to make you worse off.
Does this make sense?
OK.
So I'm going to show
you, essentially,
briefly the
experiment, the impact,
the impact of social
preference in the workplace.
So what they do is they have
really nice data from the UK--
sorry, the microphone
doesn't really work--
from the UK on fruit pickers
under different compensation
schemes.
They have a
quasi-field experiment.
They have eight weeks
in a 2002 picking season
where fruit pickers
are compensated
on a relative
performance scheme.
That is to say, the
per fruit piece rate
is decreasing in the
average productivity.
So the incentive is to
keep the productivity low
if you care about others.
Essentially, the
more you produce,
the more you get yourself,
but the other person,
everybody else, gets less.
So essentially, now
you have an incentive
to not work too hard because
if you work too hard,
other people around you
are going to be paid less.
In the next eight weeks,
however, the compensation
switched to a flat
piece rate per fruit.
And so now the
externality is shut down.
However, it doesn't
really matter for you.
It doesn't matter
how much I produce.
You essentially get
however much you produce,
or the payment for that.
The switch was announced on the
day when the change took place.
So it's kind of a
surprise to workers.
So workers were working
for eight weeks,
and then for another eight
weeks, there was a switch,
and they didn't know that this
change was going to happen.
This was a surprise
change so we shouldn't
see any anticipatory
effects of that.
Now the relative effects,
now, of this policy
depends now on this alpha term.
If I don't care about others
at all, it shouldn't matter.
I should just work really
hard, as hard as I can,
because I want to
increase my relative pay.
However, if my alpha
is high, I might
work not so hard because I'm
worried about, essentially,
my friends or co-workers
being paid less.
And here's what they find.
Essentially find a dramatic
increase in productivity.
So on the left-hand side, you
see essentially the first eight
weeks, which essentially
is their productivity.
This is kilograms per hour of
fruit that are being collected.
That goes up dramatically
in the second half.
You see on the left side, you
essentially see no pre-trend.
It doesn't look like people are
getting just more productive
over time, maybe because
they become more experienced
or they understand
better how to work fast.
It seems really flat
on the left-hand side.
On the right-hand side
it goes up by quite a bit
pretty much very quickly after
this policy is announced.
It doesn't seem there's any
other significant change.
It really seems like worker
productivity per hour goes up.
For example, the number of
workers in the same field
stays the same and so on.
It doesn't seem to be
lots of other effects.
Really, the main thing
that seems to happen
is that workers'
productivity goes up.
Is this a response to
changes in the piece rate?
No, in fact, the
piece rate went down.
How much you were rewarded
for the marginal kilogram
that you collected
actually went down.
In fact, there were incentives
to work less if you only
cared about your own output.
Also this is robust
to controlling.
So now what's going on
here, it seems to me
that workers care about others.
But not only do they
care about others,
it also seems to be
that the effects are
larger the more friends
somebody had on the field.
So some workers
have lots of friends
on the field in
the same field that
are sort of their comparison
group, and others did not.
Now why does it matter how many
friends you have in your field
if care presumably you care
more about your friends
than other people?
So now, you might have
social preferences.
You work less to help others
because if you work not very
much, they're going
to be paid more
and you might care about them.
So you work even
less when the friends
benefit because you care more
about your friends than others.
So then you should
see stronger effects
if you have more friends
on the field of the piece
rates versus the other effects.
The second part is it's
also like a repeated game,
and that's kind of a
trickier to deal with,
which is your friends might sort
of punish you in various ways.
If I work really hard, they can
see, I'm working really hard.
They might sort of punish
you socially at night,
or they might sort of be mean.
They might just not want to be
your friends anymore and so on.
It's really a mean thing
to do to your friends.
So if you do that,
you might actually not
want to work hard,
not because you
care that much about
the others, but you're
worried about,
essentially, retribution.
You're worried about
them punishing you
if you are working too fast.
Now what kind of
variation could we
look at to disentangle
those two types of effects?
So they have different types of
fruit, I can tell you already.
But what kind of
variation would we
need to disentangle
those two explanations?
Or let me ask differently.
What's crucial in part number
two for that explanation?
So I'll give you another hint.
There's raspberries
and strawberries.
For strawberries,
you can see very well
what the other person does.
For raspberries, you cannot.
And why does that matter?
AUDIENCE: Because then
your friends won't know.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
If your friends don't know--
well, if it's
explanation number one,
you really care
about your friends,
it doesn't matter
whether your friends know
or not how much you produce.
If you care about
them a lot, you're
not going to work particularly
hard because working really
hard is bad for your friends.
If instead, you're
worried about retribution,
well, then it matters a
lot whether your friend
can see what you do.
If you do the strawberries,
which [INAUDIBLE] on the field,
you can see really
easily what you do.
If that's the case, you're
going to depress your effort
in the relative pay scheme.
And then there's going to
be large effects once you
have your individual pay.
However, if you can hide
what you're doing, then
in some sense you might
work secretly really hard
in some of the bushes.
Your friends will never be
able to tell whether you
will be working hard.
And then you should
see less of an effect
when the switch happens.
And this is exactly that.
Productivity is observed
for the strawberries.
It's unobserved for raspberries.
And so what we see,
essentially, is no impact
of the piece rate for food type
number two, which essentially
is to say if you can
hide from your friends,
you will, in fact,
work really hard,
which is essentially
suggestive that you don't care
that much about your friends.
Instead, what you care
about is social sanctions
or some form of punishment,
which only happens
for the strawberries because
that's when people can actually
see what you produce.
I can maybe briefly
recap this next time.
Let me just stop here.
Next lecture, I'm going to
show you a lot more field
evidence from various settings.
Essentially, the
paper by Breza et al
that have morale effects and
so on, essentially looking at
in field situations,
I'm going to show you
that social preferences
seem to matter quite a bit.
And then in
particular, we're going
to look at the malleability
of prosociality, which
is the question of, well, should
we take social preferences
as given?
Or are there some interventions
or some policies that perhaps
could make people become
nicer or more prosocial
in some situations?
Is it something that the
government or companies
could do to get workers or
people to be more prosocial?
That's all for now.
Thanks so much.